there are some words that I can't use in
this video partly because I try not to
swear on camera and partly because I
want these videos to be suitable for
everyone no matter how conservative your
views on language are or how
conservative your parents views on
language are fortunately I am British so
there's a word that I can use instead
bloody bloody used to be a taboo word it
used to cause great offence and there's
no actual consensus as to why but these
days it's been classified as generally a
little concern by the uk's broadcasting
regulates it so I'm gonna assume that I
can get away with it but before we get
to that part of the bloody video we have
to talk about something that high school
English class probably didn't teach you
three fixers fit on the start of words
and suffixes fit on the end of words and
that's about as far as most people get
in school these are the atoms of
language these bits of meaning that
can't be split any further are called
morphemes we've talked about those
before and when a morpheme is used like
this it's called an ethics but affixes
aren't just prefixes and suffixes there
are also in fixers morphemes that slot
into the middle of a word and it is very
awkward for an English teacher to talk
about in fixes in some other languages
it would be much easier in Khmer for
example there's an infix that shows
causation so slap in Khmer means to die
but some up means to kill or to cause to
die it's more complicated in that of
course but that's a good simple example
thing you've speakers
proto-indo-european the reconstructed
ancient language that's the common
ancestor of most languages between
Iceland and India proto-indo-european
almost certainly included a nasal infix
in english a few millennia later there
is evidence of that
in one irregular verb it's the
difference between stood and stand but
modern English doesn't have in fixes
unless you count one language feature
that school kids would very much enjoy
playing around with expletive in
fixation now expletive in linguistic
terms usually means a word that's not
conveying any meaning itself but which
helps with some other goal in a sentence
like being a dummy subject so in it
round what's it the world the sky
doesn't matter it in that sentence isn't
expletive it just means we don't have to
point out the window and go right now
but expletive also has another meaning
for non linguists a curse word and
that's what we're talking about here
expletive in fixation means sticking a
curse word inside another word to add
emphasis which is fan bloody tastic yes
this is a genuine linguistics thing that
tape was written about it because it's
not a 3/4 English speakers have some
rules and patterns that we generally
stick to first rule you can't just use
any word or even any curse word as an
infix the words that can systematically
be used like this are expletives that
can already be used at almost any point
in a sentence words that will
wonderfully described as four negatives
and feel implicative x' in short it's
usually about sex so it's about asking
God to damn someone or their words
derived from those originals so freaking
flipping gosh darn
there are certainly instances where
entirely different words could be used
you can put a huge number of curses in
the middle of am so bloody lutely and
it'll sound okay because we're so used
to that construction if you like pause
the video now and try out a few of them
out loud shout them to help you have to
deal with the state of the world but
there are a few more common words that
are used for this in a 1980 article
James McMillan connected expletive in
fixation to what he called interposing
which is the interruption of any type
syntactic phrase so that would be
Mountain friggin Hammonds of bloody
course or either goddamn Newton those
interposing words can occupy spaces that
no other part of speech can they break
the rules that were taught and it turns
out you can extend that to even
interrupting in the middle of single
words so that's the words you can use
second rule you can't stick an expletive
infix anywhere in a word there is some
disagreement among phonologists about
the exact details of where they can all
fit but there's a general agreement that
the in fix has to go before a stressed
syllable and not break a morpheme into
so in bloody possible and fists of blood
agreeable are fine
but put the in fix before an unstressed
syllable and you get impossible
impossible or disagreeably ball which
all sound terrible
and that's the thing that's so
interesting about that construction
seems it's usually taboo you were likely
never taught how to you
any of those in school by an English
teacher but you knew how it works anyway
the way we learn the rules of language
without being taught them traditionally
is in bloody credible thank you to my
co-authors Molly roll and Gretchen
McCulloch Gretchen has a podcast called
enthusiasm that is well worth lesson as
a link in the description
you